bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant les
traditionnelles questions et on va pas
vous cacher les choses ça chauffe un
petit peu au sénat ça chauffe entre le
sénat et l'assemblée en ce moment même
il y à une réunion de crise ou appeler
çà comme ceux là qui se tient dans le
bureau de départ le bureau ou partira
dans un instant le président du sénat
avec une réunion autour des présidents
de groupes pourquoi parce que ce matin
et bien claude bartolone a demandé tout
simplement la suppression du sénat
réponse très proche du président du
sénat c'est non évidemment ruraux rond
toute négociation et toute discussion en
ce moment alors voilà battre dans ce
contexte qu'on accueille un autre invité
thierry bordeaux qui est secrétaire
d'état en charge de la réforme de l'état
de la simplification
c'est pas simple vous arriver dans un
contexte un peu difficile aussi au sénat
mais je veux aussi vous poser cette
question parce que vous avez été député
porte parole du groupe socialiste alors
on va d'abord écouter ce qu'elle dit
très précisément claude bartolone je
vous demande de réagir juste après
je veux pas faire plaisir à mes amis
sienne à terre mais moi je suis pour la
fin de du bicamérisme sous cette
suppression du sénat le rapprochement
entre le conseil économique et social et
le sénat pour avoir un boom de strates à
à l'allemande qui s'intéressera donc je
suis n'entend que senna quoi en tant que
senna sous la forme telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui oui je redécouvre
les textes des propositions du général
de gaulle à l'époque et je trouve qu'il
y avait déjà les résultats alors
terrible on irait vers une
simplification peut-être serré dans
votre sens mais au niveau quand même de
l'exécutif et du législatif très
compliqué de supprimer ces l'ordre mais
partout dans les démocraties
parlementaires il ya deux chambres deux
chambres élues soit au suffrage direct
pour la deuxième au suffrage indirect
il ya toujours une deuxième chambre donc
en français le sénat qui représente les
collectivités territoriales je crois que
si j'ai bien compris ce que dit claude
bartolone il considère que la deuxième
chance devrait représenter plus que les
collectivités territoriales
présenté en gros les les acteurs socio
économiques et sociaux dans la société
bon c'est un débat - le gouvernement on
a on regarde passer les balles et on est
ici au sénat
mais j'allais vite elle est apparue
depuis longtemps oui bon sinon il ya un
sujet la deuxième chance en france qui a
été posée depuis des années
la dernière fois où ça a été posé
brutalement c'est en 69 référendum que
charles de gaulle père et démissionne
mais il ya un sujet deuxième chambre
mais je crois qu'il faut aborder
sereinement tranquillement il s'agit pas
de supprimer le sénat c'est un jour il y
avait des évolutions avez peut-être
réfléchir à compléter la
représentativité de la deuxième chambre
donc si je vous entends bien au ne
supprime pas le sénat tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui c'est ce que dit le batteur
vous vous êtes plutôt contre
le gouvernement c'est pas notre affaire
peut-être intéressé vous êtes dans les
parages et aux joutes de la
sanctification non mais ce n'était pas
une question de simplification à
l'espèce ccvc se sait pas d'ailleurs
comme ça qu'il le présente c'est une
question d'une représentation différente
pour la deuxième chambre c'est pas nos
affaires on a bien assez à faire avec le
chômage l'emploi pour se mettre dans des
batailles comme celle là qu'en revanche
dans l'eure le ressourcement de la
démocratie ou réfléchissent à des
évolutions de nos institutions et
notamment par exemple celle là pourquoi
pas d'erreurs politiques comme l'eau
dans le contexte bas il ya beaucoup de
dossiers qui nécessitent à un bon
travail entre le sénat et l'assemblée il
ya des améliorations à faire par exemple
de la fabrique de la loi qui mon point
de vue aujourd'hui est très
insatisfaisant tu qui mérite une très
grosse coopération entre les présidents
du sénat et de l'assemblée je suis pas
sûr que ces déclarations contribuaient à
rabibocher oui parce que je veux je vous
donne de communiquer un calibre et le
président du sénat constatant le profond
désaccord sur les conceptions
institutionnels à un moment où la
situation du pays dans laquelle l'unité
et le rassemblement
prévost et bien pour lui les considèrent
que le travail on commente le président
de l'assemblée nationale n'est plus
possible je pense qu'il faut que tout le
monde se calme
des propos qui ont été assez anguleux
une réaction qui est extrêmement brutale
je crois qu'il faut que tout le monde
retrouve son calme et qu'on retrouve un
fonctionnement institutionnel normal
dans une république quelle que soit par
ailleurs le regard que chacun sur
l'évolution des institutions à moyen
terme la question savard rapport
forcément des conséquences sur le
travail législatif que vous allez à
mener évidemment on février au mois de
mars sur vos réformes on peut vraiment
avoir un train oui un profond malaise
entre les deux chambres en tout cas ça
peut
freiner des réformes indispensables
notamment dans la façon dont on fabrique
la loi en france la façon dont on
fabrique les lois aussi bien l'assemblée
qu'au sénat n'est pas satisfaisante en
gros un texte arrive dans une assemblée
et à des navettes y sort des deux
assemblées le texte a parfois doublée
parfois même triplé de volume donc on
fait des lois complexes bavarde illizi
peu claires sans même retouché parfois
législation précédente donc il faut
faire un effort pour mieux légiférer
c'est une urgence absolue y compris pour
que la loi puisse s'appliquer ce qui
n'est même pas toujours le cas et de ce
point de vue là pour faire ce programme
il ya des propositions très précises
faut absolument que sénat et assemblée
travaillent main dans la main ça c'est
une urgence donc oui au bicaméralisme
sur le conte problème oui au bicamérisme
bicamérisme beaucoup plus exigeants sur
la qualité de la production législative
alors en ce moment même on va passer sur
un tout autre sujet le président de la
république recevait depuis ce matin des
acteurs de la vie associative des
professeurs des gens impliqué aussi dans
les quartiers souvent assez difficile il
pourrait annoncer
éventuellement des pistes la semaine
prochaine lors de sa conférence de
presse y en a une qui est évoquée même
si ça a été démenti par notamment par
l'elysée ce matin c'est celle d'un
service civique obligatoire vous seriez
plutôt pour
compliqué à mettre en place un plan
ambitieux
organisation budget
partenaires pour que ce qui doit faire
service public obligatoire trouve
civique pardon troubler les institutions
donc donc ces genres de réformes avant
de dire on est pour on est content pour
regarder ça aussi c'est un défaut qu'on
a en france si c'est faisable il fallait
peut-être la nation de claude bartolone
et gérard larcher tout d'abord la pilule
donc d'une certaine manière ils ont
peut-être pas sur le fond mais ils ont
répondu que n'y aurait pas travailler
ensemble moi je pense que ça c'est pas
une forcément une priorité même si on
peut développer série 6 en revanche ce
que fait le président ce matin ça c'est
très bien pour deux raisons premièrement
on a un problème il sort pas une loi
tout de suite en précipitations il prend
le temps d'écouter deuxièmement plutôt
que de s'enfermer avec des experts dans
des bureaux des administrations des gens
particulièrement combattent compétents
il associe à la réflexion d une
expertise d'usagé les gens qui font sur
le terrain qui ont de l'expérience qui
trouve des solutions veut ou ce que vous
essayez de dire c'est que finalement
c'est la concertation la méthode
françois hollande c'est bien ça ben je
sais pas si en tout cas sur ce domaine
là oui et c'est très bien que de
repenser les politiques publiques pas
seulement les en sortir des
administrations centrales et plaquées
sur le terrain mais d'avoir un moment où
on essaye de faire remonter des acteurs
du terrain des idées parce que tu as
donné aussi sur le travail de
partenaires sociaux par exemple
finalement ça allait tomber sur un échec
ils ont discuté mais c'est un échec et
c'est le gouvernement qui va récupérer
qui va doit faire une loi oui mais alors
là on est dans une catégorie peu
différent particulier bruit menace des
corps intermédiaires c'est pas les
acteurs de terrain les partenaires
sociaux dont on parle c'est un une
négociation interprofessionnelle donc
cédé des corps intermédiaires c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais d'une
manière plus générale toute décision
publique qui est en partie coproduite
par les usagers ou par les acteurs de
terrain est meilleur qu une politique
publique décidée duo est plaqué sur une
société qui est en bouleversement très
profond or justement prendre un exemple
très concret il ya en ce moment la loi
macro dite loi macro évidemment qui est
en discussion à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez donné quelques quelques pistes
également dans cette longue macro il ya
des débats autour de la simplification
notamment de l'urbanisme c'est que les
verts les écologistes sont très furieux
contre ses propositions de loi et contre
ces amendements évidemment qu'ils ont
déposée par dizaines qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez aujourd'hui je pense qu on
a travaillé depuis un an sur ces en gros
sur les enquêtes publiques sur toutes
les autorisations qu'il faut avoir pour
construire y compris après le permis de
construire des autorisations
supplémentaires sur les études d'impact
qu'il faut faire une fois deux fois ou
trois fois bref on peut très facilement
raccourcir les délais d'obtention des
permis de construire raccourcir les
délais avant la construction divisé en
gros par 200 enlevé aucun droit aux
habitants de participer d'être informés
sur les conséquences environnementales
et de participer aux décisions c'est ça
qu'on va proposer et d'en dans quelques
semaines un travail méthodique on les
convaincre à yako après la loi macron
c'est dans votre travail sur la réforme
de l'état sur la simplification renommée
ou parce que c'est vrai que des gens se
disent il ya trop de paperasse il ya
trop de choses qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
eux de briller mars avril qu'est-ce que
vous annoncez en avril de nouvelles feu
annonce enfin nouvelle nouveau plan
d'action de 50 mesures pour les
entreprises et bilan des 50 mesures
annoncées il ya six mois c'est comme ça
qu'on fonctionne pas vous faire un
premier bilan oui on peut faire un
premier bilan je fais pas la liste des
mesures sur mais en 18 mois on a fait
gagner chiffres officiels validés par le
cd eu 2 4 milliards d'euros à l'économie
française du fait des mesures de
simplification vous pouvez prendre
peut-être un exemple pour que ça puisse
parler un petit peu aux gens ça serait
quelle est la plus belle réussite
finalement de ce premier bilan moi je
crois que le plus intéressant c'est la
suppression d'un certain nombre
d'obligations déclaratives des toutes
petites entreprises du pays qui font
l'essentiel du tissu économique très
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'une petite entreprise avant
chaque année devait mettre au tribunal
de commerce au greffe son bilan des
comptes annexes a séduit tout ça c'est
terminé un bilan simplifié suffit c'est
des économies de frais de comptabilité
c'est des économies de rapidité ccc
permettre aux petites entreprises de se
concentrer ce sur quoi elles sont faits
c'est à dire produire vous parlez de
rapidité et d'efficacité il ya aussi un
projet qu'on consent venir en tout cas
vous savez quand on doit remplir sa
feuille d'impôts soit l'envoi par
courrier sur le fait par internet
d'abord par internet ça va devenir
obligatoire c'est ce qui se murmure en
tout cas alors c'est loin d'être fait
c'est peut-être une idée qu'il ya dans
les cartons de bercy ça existe dans un
certain nombre de pays étrangers en
angleterre c'est obligatoire en
allemagne c'est semi obligatoire donc
fort les gens sont fortement incités
dans ces pays là vous avez jusqu'à 83%
de déclarations faites en ligne d'impôts
en angleterre enfin sonné à 33% mais
c'est vrai que déclarer en ligne c'est
beaucoup moins coûteux pour
l'administration c'est beaucoup plus
facile pour l'usagé il ses pertes en
permanence ce qu'il doit régler peut
même faire varier ses prélèvements
mensuels donc ça plein davantage mais
attends sacs des avantages visible
attention il ya deux choses qui sont
importants les mesures comme cela si
elle était décidée demain
et en régime progressivement sur
plusieurs années parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui ne se sert pas l'internet qui
ne savent pas se servir d'internet et
dont on peut penser qu'ils sont pas
prêts de savoir à jour première chose
deuxième chose il faut veiller à chaque
étape à ce que les personnes qui ont
besoin d'être accompagnés qui doivent
avoir un point d'accueil des guichets
physiques puisse le faire c'est pas
parce que tout est fait par
téléprocédures que doivent disparaître
les guichets et les accompagnements des
usagers car il nourrit à priori ça
serait pour cause je ne sais pas si
cette mesure sera décidé je sais que
bercy travaille à un projet de
simplification fiscale que la loi en
question devraient arriver juste avant
l'été le web mais a priori c'est ça et
que c'est dans ce cadre là j'imagine que
l'inventaire des possibles est réalisée
parmi ces inventaires des possibles il
semble que bercy tout cas
l'administration soient attachés à cette
mesure faut être prudent faut être
prudent si on se donne le temps si on se
donne les moyens ça se regarde j'aurai
une question plus politique dans un
instant si on reste un petit peu sur
cette simplification c'est dur
aujourd'hui de simplifier cette lourdeur
de l'état français oui c'est dur pour
une raison c'est que en france on a la
fascination du maquereau on à la
fascination de la grande mesure qui
change tout 1e puis d'ailleurs c'est pas
le concept arrivé aux manettes pour ce
secrétariat d'état quand vous avez vu la
masse qui vous arrive et vous avez des
examens possibles images et moi je suis
persuadé pour simplifier c'est la
méthode qu'on a mis en place c'est la
méthode que esther duflo met en place
sur les six 6 ans économique par exemple
il faut faire les choses à l'envers
c'est à dire qu'il faut décortiquer
chaque acte administratif
regardez pourquoi il est complexe
qu'elle complexité créé pour l'usager et
reconstruire une politique plus public
plus simplifié mais qui elles partent du
visage et lui la réforme territoriale
puisqu'on en est là parce qu'on est au
sénat l'a été votée ici au sénat mardi
elle est un petit peu refaite à la
version de la droite ici et notamment
avec une défense des départements ça va
dans le sens justement de cette
simplification par
weepu oui en tout cas on a du mal à y
comprendre vraiment c'est une
simplification c'est assez simple cet
espace de mille feuille territorial en
elle-même bon il ya moins de
collectivités donc on peut considérer
s'il y en a moins c'est mieux c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche mais cette
organisation nouvelle territoriale
oblige l'état maintenant c'est un
travail qu'on va faire dans les trois
mois qui viennent à se réorganiser lui
même sur la base de ces nouvelles
grandes régions très concrètement ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nous
allons avoir treize grandes préfecture
de région et à correspondant peu ou coup
avec l'épaule et même plutôt pop même
complètement avec les nouvelles régions
collectivités territoriales nous allons
repenser le rôle exact des préfectures
départementales
donc nous sommes obligés de nous aussi
d'adapter et de remettre un système en
parallèle qui fonctionne beaucoup plus
précisément est mieux ensemble entre
collectivités et état c'est ça qui
produit à la fin une plus grande
lisibilité du système de décision et de
la simplicité quand je vous parlais de
des questions politiques et ont
forcément un lien avec ces élections
aussi départementale qui vont arriver
d'ici peu de temps en mars prochain oomu
dit visiblement que du côté de la gauche
et vous allez peut-être confirmé il ya
une sorte de regard de forme qu'on
espère que vous allez pouvoir regagner
quelques quelques départements qui
étaient sensiblement perdu ou pas alors
écoutez on va parler de l'élection de
dimanche jusqu'à maintenant les partiels
c'est simple on n'est pas au deuxième
tour
on n'est pas au deuxième tour là je fais
le pari qu'on sera au deuxième tour et
qu'on peut gagner cette élection merci
beaucoup tiré mon dos je vais donner la
parole deux petites secondes avant que
avant qu'ils regagnent l'hémicycle à
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
ump vous sortez du bureau de départ pour
cent qui est quand même un point de
friction que l'assemblée où en est on ce
n'est pas avec l'assemblée savait que
les propos de claude bartolone qui est
par ailleurs président de l'assemblée le
président du cian a souhaité nous réunir
c'est à dire l'ensemble des pressions de
groupes je pense que tous ensemble on a
manifesté notre désaccord profond quel
que soit d'ailleurs la couleur de tel ou
tel groupe avec ses propos voilà hélas
dans un instant vous allez prendre la
parole dans les mythiques ans de mandat
si vous permettez je la prendrai vous
écoutez à mes collègues du quinquennat
très gentil d'être sorti du bureau
départ pour venir nous raconter un peu
ce qu'il est assez merci beaucoup baudot
retailleau thierry bourdon je vous
laisse évidemment regagner les bords des
minispaces que vous allez évidemment
écouter toutes ces questions d'actualité
ensemble vous avez vu que gérard larcher
s'est installé en haut de la tribune
pour présider cette séance de questions
d'actualité de nombreuses questions aux
traits cette semaine notamment sur
ça aura sur auschwitz là on va encore en
reparler c'est jean marc todeschini qui
va en parler notamment le secrétaire
d'état en charge des anciens combattants
qui prendra la parole des questions
aussi de justice on a vu tout à l'heure
passée sur les images christiane taubira
la ministre qui s'exprimera également
sur une question sur l'impact de la
politique pénale il y aura également une
question posée à michel sapin sur le
recours à la titrisation des banques
je vous laisse écouter cette séance on
va revenir tout à l'heure et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement la séance
est retransmise en direct sur france 3
et public sénat et
j'ai réuni les présidents de groupe et
exceptionnellement il y aura un rappel
au règlement le premier qui ait demandé
d'arriver et celui de monsieur bruno
retailleau
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues en déclarant ce matin je suis
je cite pour la suppression du sénat en
tant que senna sous la forme que l'on
connaître aujourd'hui le président de
l'assemblée nationale claude bartolone a
commis une faute en prononçant des
propos d'une particulière gravité
ces propos sont graves d'abord parce
qu'il est sous-entendre que le travail
du sénat ne vaut rien faut-il rappeler
au président de l'assemblée nationale
que 73% des amendements qui sont
fabriqués voter ici sont repris par les
députés faut-il rappeler à monsieur
bartolone que beaucoup de textes qui
nous viennent de l'assemblée sont remis
sur l'ouvragé ici pour en faire des
textes juridiquement plus précis faut-il
lui rappeler que sur le dernier texte
territoriale de nombreux élus de droite
et de gauche ont souligné la qualité du
sénat visiblement monsieur bartolone a
beaucoup de mal à supporter la qualité
de nos travaux grave aussi parce qu'il
contredit ses propres propos en avril
dernier le sénat était de gauche il y
avait un colloque sur le bicamérisme
monsieur bartolone déclare
tout ça est très bien puisque le sénat a
connu l'alternance si je comprend bien
son raisonnement monsieur le président
dès lors que le sénat est de gauche ça
n'est plus une anomalie démocratique
quand le sénat revient de droite il
faudrait le supprimer
décidément monsieur bartolone a une
conception toute personnelle de la
démocratie et enfin grave ces propos
parce qu'en attaquant de façon
spectaculaire violente frontal le sénat
dans son existence même
monsieur bartolone rond l'unité
nationale souhaitait pourtant par le
président de la république
le sénat ne sera jamais dos il vise à
vide aucune majorité c'est son adn le
sénat restera enraciné dans nos
territoires le sénat restera exigent
notamment intellectuellement et sur son
activité législative c'est le sénat que
nous aimons c'est le sénat que nous
voulons c'est de cela qu'il faut pour la
république française
je suis saisi la deuxième rappel au
règlement du président mézard puis du
président capoue canelas
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues oui
comme comme tant d'autres ici
j'ai été particulièrement choquée par
les propos du président barcelone
toutes les idées toutes les expressions
sont recevables en démocratie mais celui
qui s'est exprimé c'est le président de
l'assemblée nationale
et ce n'est jamais neutre d'autant que
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas la première
fois que c'est répétitif que depuis des
mois et des mois ici je dis et je pense
qu'il y a une volonté peut être pas
majoritaires mais existante au sein de
l'exécutif de supprimer la haute
assemblée et que là dessus il faut être
clair il est des moments qui sont des
moments de vérité
si c'est le cas dites le mesdames et
messieurs les ministres et puis nous
apprécierons d'autres ont essayé à
d'autres époques
le sénat c'est vrai et je parle
aujourd'hui en tant que président d'un
groupe peu nombreux en nombre mais dont
la vie se confond avec l'avis de la
haute assemblée
qu'il a longtemps présidé qui a su
résister à d'autres époques et bien le
sénat c'est l'expression de la liberté
cette liberté que nous partageons tous
et que nous avons souvent et je le dis à
mes amis socialistes que nous avons
souvent l'occasion d'exprimer au delà
des sensibilités diverses nous l'avons
fait ensemble sous la présidence du
président sarkozy nous l'avons fait
souvent aussi ensemble sur des textes
économique j'ai voté le budget je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas chers collègues
carrère parce que ce qui risque de nous
est posée de nous opposer est quelque
chose de fondamental
le we came riches nous y sommes
fondamentalement attaché notre histoire
notre vie
et il est dramatique
que quelques heures après une émission
qui n'honore pas le service public le
président de l'assemblée nationale
dans une période de volonté d'un grand
consensus sur les valeurs fondamentales
de la république
s'exprime de cette manière là et je ne
peux pas penser que ce soit un écart de
langage devant des journalistes qu'il a
l'habitude de côtoyer tout le temps il y
a une volonté il y a une expression et
bien cette expression cette volonté
comme d'autres l'ont fait ici à des
périodes encore plus difficile nous
allons nous la combattre avec force avec
conviction parce que ce n'est pas bien
on ne veut pas constamment remettre en
cause les institutions et puis il faut
aussi mes chers collègues avoir une
cohérence dans l'expression je le disais
sur la réforme territoriale
je le dis là aussi vous avez été
nombreux mes chers collègues ici à faire
campagne au mois de septembre dernier
pour vous faire réélire je n'en connais
pas beaucoup qui sont allés dire dans
nos territoires et dans nos campagnes
supprimons le sénat
lorsque et j'avais voté pour lui lorsque
le président bel a été élu
vous avez magnifier mes chers collègues
socialistes l'image du sénat et je vais
vous et je vais vous lire ce qu'il a dit
dans son discours d'investiture
nous avons tous entendu l'appel des
grands électeurs pour confirmer le sénat
dans son rôle de représentant et de
défenseurs des libertés publiques des
libertés individuelles des libertés
locales et je souscris et nous
souscrivons totalement à ces propos les
quant aux déclarations du président
bartolone ici même en avril 2014
le bicamérisme et l'alliance de la
puissance coisy sacré du suffrage
universel direct et de la richesse de
nos territoires il est la vie et
l'histoire des individus ancré dans la
diversité de notre géographie ainsi le
bicamérisme et la traduction
institutionnelle de ce qui caractérise
notre pays l'unité dans la diversité et
vient mes chers collègues dans le sens
de ces magnifiques propos du président
bartolome exprimons un message fort nous
avons besoin de nous moderniser mais
toutes les assemblées ont besoin de se
moderniser et il en est qui ferait mieux
de balayer devant leur porte avant de
donner des leçons aux autres
monsieur capo-canellas sur le groupe
centriste
merci merci monsieur monsieur le
président je veux après les présidents
retailleau et méar dire combien le
groupe u10 us et du sénat a été étonné
et super fait des déclarations du
président de l'assemblée nationale ce
matin et je souhaite simplement
réaffirmer ici notre conception d'un
sénat défenseurs des libertés comme ça a
toujours été sa tradition par la
démocratie française d'un sénat au
service des territoires passionnément à
même d'apporter sa valeur ajoutée dans
l'écriture de la loi nous croyons au
bicamérisme et nous croyants un sénat
qui comme toujours c'est dépassé le
temps court de l'actualité politique
pour éclairer l'avenir qui sait aussi
bâtir des consensus et c'est notre rôle
ici la haute assemblée a toujours montré
qu'elle était à même de dépasser les
clivages pour parfois mener dans
l'esprit de réforme des projets qui
étaient utiles à l'avenir du pays et
nous sommes étonnés et finalement nous
ne comprenons pas que le président d'une
assemblée se permettent comme ça de
critiquer l'autre assemblée au delà de
toute tradition de dialogue républicain
et parlementaires et nous souhaitons
aussi que cet esprit de réforme que le
sénat a toujours porté nous continuons à
l'appliquer à nous-mêmes à notre
institution et monsieur le président
nous voulons simplement vous dire notre
confiance en travail que vous avez
engagé déjà lors de votre premier mandat
et que vous poursuivez en ce moment au
sein de différents groupes de travail
pour la modernisation de nos travaux et
de la modernisation de notre institution
je le dis avec confiance au moment où
une émission de télévision chacun le
sait a de manière caricaturale sans
aucune comparaison internationale et de
manière tout à fait volontairement
tendancieuses
dénigrer notre maison nous savons nous
avons un devoir de modernisation elle
est engagée et nous le ferons en
concertation avec nos agents dont je
veux saluer le professionnalisme
le groupe idi uc et le sénat sera
rassemblée monsieur le président à vos
côtés pour défendre l'institution et la
démocratie dont le bicamérisme jour
merci mais si mon cher collègue à
l'homme la présidente eliane assassi
merci les streakers citoyens merci
monsieur le président écoute et pour ma
part je trouve que les propos dit les
propos de monsieur bartolone de ce matin
sont pour le moins
maladroit voire
regrettera maladroit parce que il me
semble qu'on ne peut pas jeter en pâture
comme ça un sujet aussi important que le
devenir de nos institutions
et donc de notre démocratie en pâture
comme ça devant sur un plateau de
télévision et c'est regrettable aussi
parce que claude bartolone je crois
savoir a mis en place un groupe de
travail de réflexion sur le devenir et
la modernisation de nos de nos
institutions et donc il faut laisser le
temps au temps et que ce groupe de
réflexion puisse travailler avant de
faire des annonces comme celle de ce
matin je trouve que c'est aussi
regrettable car ces propos peuvent
contribuer vous le savez bien mes chers
collègues à nourrir la défiance
populaire à l'égard du politique et du
personnel politique avec les possibles
dérives populistes que cela peut créer
alors moi je dois vous le dire et je
l'avais dit au moment du débat sur du
colloque sur le bicamérisme les élus que
nous sommes sont sont pour le
bicamérisme mais dans le cadre d'une
vième république
rénovée ça fait longtemps que nous
demandons ce débat et je pense qu'il est
temps que ce débat ait lieu mais que ce
débat ait lieu en grande responsabilité
dans la plus grande des sérénités et
avec la plus grande transparence
possible je crois que nous de nous le
devons à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
et de nos concitoyennes merci madame la
présidente lucile président sueur
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues en ce lieu au victor
schoelcher s'est levé pour abolir
l'esclavagé ou victor hugo a défendu le
progrès les libertés et la république
nous défendons le sénat non pas parce
qu'il s'agirait de défendre de manière
corporatiste une institution mais nous
défendons le sénat parce que nous sommes
profondément attachés au travail que
nous y faisons tous et dans une émission
qui est passé hier le grand tort c'est
qu'on n'a pas parlé du travail
législatif
du travail de contrôle de la
représentation de tous nos départements
quels qu'ils soient et mes chers
collègues nous sommes profondément pour
le bicamérisme pourquoi
parce que s'il ya une assemblée unique
il n'y a plus de navettes il n'y a plus
de débat il n'y a plus ce long travail
d'élaboration de la loi parce que toute
ligne dans la loi tout mot dans la loi
s'applique au peuple français tout
entier et notre dignité c'est de passer
des jours des nuits le temps qu'il faut
pour que la loi soit la meilleure
possible
chacun avec nos convictions si nous
défendons le sénat c'est pas pour
défendre une institution c'est pour
défendre la loi l'esprit de la loi la
constitution de la loi par les
représentants du peuple
indissociable de la république
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est au président jean vincent
placé du groupe écologiste monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je crois
que nous sommes à peine trois semaines
après les événements dramatiques qui ont
frappé notre pays à peine deux semaines
après la mobilisation exemplaire de nos
concitoyens pour rappeler l'importance
de l'unité du rassemblement dans
l'attachement aux valeurs de la
république et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que tout ce qui peut aujourd'hui
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des failles
des espaces des débuts division dans
cette unité ce rassemblement et bien
tout cela est inappropriée et en ce sens
là
l'intervention du président l'assemblée
nationale était tout à la fois
inadaptée
inopportune et dans un temps politique
qui n'est pas convenable
quand nous avons dit cela je le souhaite
nous ne pouvons pas être seulement sur
la défensive sur le bicamérisme nous les
parlementaires écologistes du sénat de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons
toujours été pour le bicamérisme nous
pensons que le fait qu'on ne réagisse
pas dans l'immédiateté à l'assemblée
nationale chambre unique dans un temps
de la vème république ou avec le
quinquennat juste après l'élection
présidentielle
un mois plus tard on donne des majorité
absolue avec 27 28 % des voix au parti
du président on pense que c'est d'autant
plus important qu'il y ait un
bicamérisme c'est même essentiel qui est
la discussion de la navette c'est
essentiel qu'on prenne le temps de faire
les lois on le voit sur les sujets
graves qui sont ceux d'aujourd'hui sur
le terrorisme sur la sécurité du pays
sur la nécessité de renforcer les
valeurs de la république à l'école ou de
nos politiques de la ville qu'on ne peut
pas par ce biais un tel événement aussi
dramatique soit ils réagir dans les 24
48 heures pour faire la loi rapidement à
l'assemblée nationale c'est cela que
nous devons dire et il est évident que
le bicamérisme est fondamentalement pour
un pays comme le nôtre dans les
institutions qui sont les nôtres mais je
vous le dis aussi
avec la franchise la sincérité que nous
nous devons
l'émission d'hier était catastrophique
pour l'image du sénat mais la seule
réponse et je l'entends ça ne peut pas
être de dire c'est affreux journalistes
gauchistes la chaîne publique mes chers
collègues de l'ump nous avons une
nécessité de nous renforcer nous ne
devons pas être sur la défensive et
quelque part nous devons répondre au
président bartolone que nous sommes
utiles que nous travaillons que ça a été
happée 73% des éléments de la loi des
textes proviennent du sénat nous devons
aussi être exemplaire nous devons être
transparents temps sur les comptes de la
maison senna temps sur les comptes des
groupes politiques tant sur les comptes
de l'irfm temps sur tout ce qui
constitue la vie du sénateur nous ne
pouvons plus être dans la situation de
1958 alors oui à l'unité et au
rassemblement
oui au sénat oui au bicamérisme oury à
la rénovation à la modernité et ayant le
souci et je dis je tiens à saluer
l'action de notre président gérard
larcher allons vers la rénovation du
sénat c'est ça la bonne réponse à
apporter au président bartolone merci
mes chers collègues
je vous donne acte de l'ensemble des
rappels au règlement j'aurais simplement
vous dire que j'ai été élu président du
sénat que vous ayez ou non voter pour
moi pour avoir la responsabilité
conduire cette institution le
bicamérisme c'est plus de démocratie
c'est plus de liberté c'est plus de
représentations dans la diversité des
territoires et que cette responsabilité
je l'assumerai totalement pleinement
sans faiblesse vous pouvez me faire
confiance on me dit parfois rond je suis
aussi un homme de décision et
d'engagement et j'ai pas besoin de tout
clivage est besoin qu'on soit rassemblés
autour d'un projet qu'est celui de la
république y compris quand on pense 6e
moi je suis fondamentalement un homme
qui croit à la cinquième qui a
d'ailleurs démontré au mois de janvier
qu'elle était bien utile pour permettre
au président de la république le
traverser des moments difficiles je le
dis aussi nos deux groupes de travail
fonctionne il vous faudra aussi du sens
de la responsabilité
une forme de courage parce qu'il faudra
tout simplement tout simplement que nous
adaptions le mode de fonctionnement de
nos assemblées et pas simplement du
sénat parce que le bicamérisme ce sont
deux assemblées qui fonctionne qui
dialoguent et ça passe aussi par les
commissions mixtes paritaires qui ne
soit pas caricatural c'est ça aussi le
fonctionnement mais vous ne serez pas
déçus me semble-t-il par les
propositions que nos trois rapporteurs
vous feront le moment venu il faudra du
courage je crois que le sénat ait
fondamentalement utile à la république
et que dans ces temps de crise et de
désarroi on ne peut pas jouer comme ça
avec les institutions de la république
je le redis l'unité nationale le sursaut
qui veut dire aussi la diversité nous en
avons besoin je voulais simplement
informé sénat que je poursuivrai j'en ai
informé le président de la république la
mission sur l'engagement républicain et
sentiment d'appartenance nationale qu'il
avait souhaitée que je puisse conduire
je lui remettrai directement mes
réflexions à la fin mars parce que je
pense qu'il est de ma responsabilité
avec vous de contribuer à la réflexion
collective nous avons besoin de nous
sentir de la même république j'allais
dire quel qu'en soit le numéro pour
ensemble être attaché aux valeurs
fondamentales de notre pays dans l'idée
de la modernité puisant dans les
traditions la force du devenir merci
alors
mais nous étions en question d'actualité
ai-je excuses ce qui sans doute
la parole à monsieur françois aubé pour
le groupe socialiste vous avez la parole
mon cher collègue merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état chargé des
anciens combattants et de la mémoire
le 27 janvier 1945 est une date à jamais
gravé dans la mémoire de l'humanité
il ya 70 ans les troupes soviétiques
découvrez dans le camp d'extermination
d'auschwitz birkenau à l'ouest de
cracovie en pologne
où plus d'un million d'hommes de femmes
et d'enfants ont été tuées est libéré
plus de sept mille détenus survivants et
découvrent et surtout l'horreur de ce
qu'on allait appeler la shoah
ce n'est que plus tard que l'opinion
publique mondiale devait prendre
conscience de l'ampleur de la solution
finale organisée dans les camps du
troisième reich à savoir l'extermination
méthodique
programme et scientifiques des juifs
la shoah est le plus grand crime jamais
commis ce crime perpétré en terre
d'europe fut unique par son ampleur six
millions de victimes parmi lesquelles un
million et demi d'enfants
soit les trois quarts des juifs d'europe
plus du tiers de la population juive
dans le monde
la république française une et
indivisible
n'oubliera jamais comme en a pris
l'engagement le président de la
république ce mardi au mémorial de la
shoah
ce devoir de mémoire est un combat qui
ne saurait être conforté simplement les
jours de commémoration la transmission
nouvelle génération de ce que fut la
shoah est aujourd'hui de notre
responsabilité
lutter contre l'oubli
l'ignorance et faire en sorte que les
français de confession juive se sentent
pleinement chez eux dans notre pays doit
demeurer une priorité
vous le savez les inquiétudes sont vives
que ce soit à toulouse en mars 2012 en
décembre dernier à créteil où il ya
encore trois semaines lors de la taille
du supermarché cacher de la porte de
vincennes et plus globalement au
quotidien dans nos rues dans les cours
de nos écoles sur nos réseaux sociaux
personne personne ne peut nier
aujourd'hui que le fléau de
l'antisémitisme est bien là utilisant
toujours les mêmes ressorts les mêmes
thèses complotistes ou négationnistes la
même haine de l'autre
monsieur secrétaire d'état il en va de
notre responsabilité collective d'être
intraitable sur la question de la
mémoire
de la sécurité des juifs de france mais
aussi en matière de sanction qui doit
être forte et adapté
pouvons nous confirmer que les sanctions
à l'encontre des actes racistes et
antisémites is vont être renforcés comme
l'a annoncé le chef de l'état je vous
remercie
merci mon cher collègue dans cette
question grave la parole est à notre
collègue par notre ancien collègue jean
marc todeschini secrétaire d'état chargé
les anciens combattants de la mémoire
merci monsieur le président j'ai le
réflexe mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur ob mais tout
d'abord j'aurais vous dire que je suis
fier d'intervenir devant de votre haute
assemblée et que la présence nombreuse
des membres du gouvernement montre
l'attachement et le respect que nous
portons à votre assemblée voilà
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur de
sénateur ob le président de la
république a annoncé la mise en place
d'un plan global de lutte contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme
ce plan appelle notamment le
renforcement des sanctions à l'encontre
des porteurs de haine en ce sens le
premier ministre est intervenu notamment
devant les assemblées à plusieurs
reprises c'est bien mais bien l'ensemble
du gouvernement qui est mobilisé et tout
particulièrement le ministre l'intérieur
madame la ministre de la justice le
ministre de la défense la ministre de
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui en
france
personne ne doit avoir peur personne ne
doit avoir peur parce qu'il est juif
personne ne doit avoir peur parce qu'il
est musulman personne ne doit avoir peur
parce qu'il est catholique
personne ne doit avoir peur parce qu'ils
croient ou parce qu'ils ne croient pas
la laïcité c'est le ciment de la nation
le fondement de notre république
l'état se doit de le garantir
d'abord en mobilisant les forces
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité de
tous cela a été le cas
immédiatement à la suite des lâches
attentats du mois de janvier ça a été la
première réponse ensuite en améliorant
la visibilité bien entendu et
d'efficacité des sanctions
le président de la république l'a
souligné mardi au mémorial de la shoah à
l'occasion de la commémoration du 70e
anniversaire de la libération du camp
d'auschwitz lors de cette cérémonie de
nombreux déportés étaient présents et
leur présence à conférer un moment
d'émotion intense
à la cérémonie mais après l'émotion née
l'incontournable d'un incontournable
besoin de responsabilité après le
silence n'est besoin de parole une
parole qui raconte qui doit témoigner
qui doit transmettre
je remercie en tout cas d'avoir rappelé
la nécessité d'un renforcement des
sanctions
tout gouvernement est pleinement engagée
mais aussi vous avez évoqué le devoir
nécessaire de mémoire tampon ne
permettrai de citer quelques actions de
mon ministère
le président de la république a annoncé
toujours mardi une réflexion nous
engageons de l'engagement d'une
réflexion sur le concours national de la
résistance et de la déportation
ce concours doit associer plus de jeunes
venant de tous les horizons venant et il
faut rendre je dirais une connaissance
meilleur pour le grand public dont tout
cela est nécessaire car seul le savoir
la connaissance la transmission
inviteront la clairvoyance sur les
sujets de vous avez évoqué en tout cas
tous ceux qui diraient met en cause les
mémoires qui bête on pose les mémoires
collectives toutes les mémoires doivent
savoir qu'ils trouveront sur leur chemin
la république et puis les en tout cas
les valeurs de la république nous sommes
là pour défendre le fondement de cette
république et les trois piliers que sont
la liberté l'égalité et la fraternité je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à notre collègue élisabeth
doineau pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants union
centriste vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le 15 janvier dernier la
banque nationale suisse a décidé
d'abandonner la parité fixe qu'il y ait
le franc suisse à l'euro
après s'être apprécié de plus de 20% le
franc suisse cote désormais à parité
avec l'euro
20% c'est colossal monsieur le ministre
du budget et malheureusement cela a des
conséquences désastreuses pour de
nombreuses collectivités
une fois de plus la douloureuse question
des créances toxiques de nos territoires
est donc posée
en effet pendant les années 2000 de
nombreuses collectivités on pensait
profiter de l'euphorie liée à la bulle
financière
sous l'affluence de banquiers peu
scrupuleux
plus de 1500 collectivités et
établissements publics se sont endettés
en souscrivant des emprunts dont les
taux d'intérêt pour temps variable était
fréquemment libellés en francs suisses
alors jugé très stable la suite vous la
connaissez déjà trop bien la crise
financière a conduit à une envolée des
taux d'intérêt
devenu purement et simplement usuriers
de nombreuses collectivités
mais pas seulement des communes des
départements mais aussi des
établissements publics des hôpitaux font
face à une situation financière
alarmante qui remet parfois en cause
jusqu'à leur capacité à assurer la
continuité du service public le stock
d'emprunts contractés restent immenses
et son volume explose sous l'effet de
l'appréciation du franc suisse
le fonds de soutien que vous avez créées
sous dimensionné et ne permet pas de
faire face aux échéances de
remboursement or vous avait gelé les
voies d'action contentieuse contre ces
contrats à l'occasion de la loi de
sécurisation des contrats de prêts
structurés nous voilà donc face à une
créance dont le coût réel que tu
exploses est une nouvelle fois du simple
fait d'une décision prise par une
autorité étrangère
cette situation n'est pas acceptable
nos concitoyens sont prisonniers sont
pris en otages de créances qui ont
parfois été contractée il ya plus de dix
ans et parfois par des équipes qui ont
été renouvelés à deux reprises entre
temps au delà du risque financier
il ya désormais un vrai problème
démocratique posés par ces emprunts les
élus locaux sont impuissants pour y
répondre
aussi monsieur le ministre je vous
appelle à l'aide je souhaiterais
connaître vos réponses afin de pallier
aux effets du désordre monétaire suisse
sur nos finances locales et je vous en
remercie
pour vous répondre merci ma chère
collègue la parole est à christian
eckert secrétaire d'état en charge du
budget merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice élisabeth doineau le
gouvernement a constaté comme vous que
la brute à l'appréciation du franc
suisse
que personne n'avait anticipé à ce stade
provoque une situation pour le moins
d'inquiétude parfois plus au sein des
collectivités dont vous avez rappelé que
certaines ont pu choisir à un moment
donné
d'opter pour un type de prêts structurés
à risque
dont d'autres ont parfois été victimes
d'une politique commerciale agressive
de dexia c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire
dont le gouvernement précédent a tiré
les consoles les conséquences en logeant
dans une structure qui s'appelle les
fils les emprunts toxiques
avec il faut le savoir la garantie de
l'état
que le parlement a accepté de donner je
crois que c'est en 2010 à cette nouvelle
structure est qu'une défaillance de
l'asf il serait immanquablement pris en
charge par l'ensemble des contribuables
français par le budget de notre pays
nous avons donc une situation très
complexe ou des responsabilités sont à
l'évidence partagez vous avez rappelé
que le gouvernement avec l'appui de deux
assemblées a mis en place un fonds
d'appui aux collectivités
avec barème d'accompagnement qui
aujourd'hui devra être revue à
l'évidence puisque la nouvelle donne
doit être apprécié c'est parce que cette
nouvelle donne doit être appréciée dans
la durée parce que les mouvements d'une
monnaie peuvent connaître des
soubresauts et ensuite envisager une
stabilisation plus grande que le
gouvernement a commencé à travailler
avec michel sapin avec nos services avec
les représentants de la ce fil nous
sommes en train de quantifier si j'ose
dire la nouvelle donne dont le coût à
l'évidence ne sera pas nulles et peut
atteindre plusieurs centaines voire
voire plus d'un ou
j'espère pas plus milliards d'euros et
donc en fonction de salle nous recevrons
dans les jours qui viennent les
représentants des collectivités à savoir
l'association qui s'est créée à cet
effet les représentants de la mf de
l'adf de l'aef mais aussi de certains
secteurs hospitalier vous les avez
mentionné avec marisol touraine nous
allons voir comment les nouvelles règles
pourront au mieux connaître une
adéquation avec la nouvelle donne qui
n'a pas échappé bien entendu
gouvernement surtout au moment où
beaucoup de d'élus locaux sont en train
de prévoir le vote de leur budget merci
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
notre collègue jacques grosperrin pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole merci
président ma qui sont s'adresse à madame
taubira garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice madame la ministre notre pays
tout entier s'y retrouver dans un élan
sincère unanimes pour dénoncer la
barbarie qui a frappé notre sol vous
défendre la démocratie la liberté la
république et ses valeurs mais que
faisons-nous maintenant l'unité
nationale ne doit pas devenir un petit
calcul politicien visant à étouffer
l'opposition a rappelé notre président
bruno retailleau c'est notre devoir de
parler sans concession au gré des
déclarations de celle du premier
ministre l'examen de conscience que nous
espérions tarde à venir le déni est
toujours là alors que l'horreur l
urgence de la situation commande est la
rupture lorsque le premier ministre a
dénoncé l'apartheid social persiste et
signe et nous savons que cela va
renforcer le sentiment de victimisation
d'une population convaincu de souffrir
sous un joug quasi coloniale comment
alors espérer faire tomber les tensions
lorsque manuel valls dit à la jeunesse
qu'il doit s'habituer à vivre
durablement avec la menace terroriste
que penser impuissance pour certains
calculs pour d'autres lorsque vous
madame la garde des sceaux vous opposé
d'emblée au retour de la peine da
dignité nationale alors que le premier
ministre a justement proposé aux deux
présidents des commissions des
assemblées de réfléchir sur le sujet de
faire des propositions il y à un malaise
le défi de la lutte antiterroriste
appelle le réel changement dans le
seulement de la justice pour mes
collègues et moi même c'est moi la loi
elle même qui pose problème que son
exécution nous considérons que vous avez
un mort c'est madame la ministre un
véritable désarmement pénale très
préjudiciable au pays si de loi inspiré
pour partie par la président précédente
majorité après la ferme et rats ont
renforcé récemment notre droit la
réforme pénale de 2014 et symbolique
d'une moindre rigueur dans l'exécution
des peines
exit ce qui a été appelé bien
abusivement le tout carcéral vie dans
les prisons allégeant le régime des
sanctions pénales des récidivistes et
facilitons les libérations de prison le
plan quinquennal de construction de
prisons prévues en 2011 a été purement
et simplement supprimées alors qu'il
faudrait 30 mille places suppression des
peines plancher contre 1,2 pénale
aménagement de peine plus qu'une peine
est tendue d'ailleurs ou délits
passibles de 10 ans de prison sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve une aubaine pour
les djihadistes autant de réponses
positives gravement inadaptés en cette
période très troublée nous travaillons
en ce moment au sein du groupe ump à des
propositions dans différents traits du
direction dont les plus difficiles tels
la nationalité
nous les ferons connaître pour l'heure
pouvez vous nous dire madame la garde
des sceaux aussi de votre côté vous
souhaitez enfin et faire évoluer votre
politique pénale dans ce contexte de
lutte contre le terrorisme et comment le
ferez vous merci mon cher collègue
madame christiane taubira garde des
sceaux vous avez la parole madame la
ministre le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur grosperrin en vous
écoutant en tout cas la fin de votre
question je réalisais que le contenu de
votre question suggéré que vous n'avez
pas le temps de prendre connaissance des
dispositions qui sont contenues dans la
réforme pénale donc qui est une loi
d'individues d'individualisation de la
peine et de renforcement de l'efficacité
des sanctions pénales c'est un texte de
loi qui a été conçu de façon extrêmement
rigoureuse puisqu'il avait il a donné
lieu à une conférence de consensus qui a
rassemblé des personnes y compris de
votre sensibilité politique puisque nous
avons tenu à rassembler des expériences
des réflexions extrêmement diverses etc
évaluation extrêmement rigoureuse qui a
été portée sur les politiques pénales
précédente qui nous ont conduit à
définir le contenu de ce texte qui a été
d'ailleurs abondamment de travailler ici
au sénat le il est évident que
l'efficacité des sanctions pénales est
liée à l'individualisation de la peine
donc nous avons introduit des
dispositions pour permettre pour rester
pour rendre aux magistrats leur liberté
d'appréciation de façon à définir très
précisément l'ascension qui sera la plus
efficace une autre des dispositions
importantes c'est d'éviter que les
personnes qui ont été incarcérés sortent
sans aucun encadrement sans aucun suivi
sans aucune contrainte c'était le cas de
la politique pénale je pourrais
facilement vous dire que la politique
pénale précédente que nous avons évalué
était une politique qui multipliait les
récidives puisque le taux de récidive a
été multiplié par trois entre 2001 et
2011 et c'est pas nous ce n'est pas nous
qui avons fait cette appréciation
la surpopulation carcérale la sortie
avec le site le système de surveillance
de fin de peine qui est un automatisme
sans aucun suivi sans aucun contrôle
sans aucun encadrement a donné des
résultats désastreux donc nous avons
voulu changer de ça et nous avons fait
le choix d'une politique pénale
responsables et nous l'assumons
concernant la lutte contre le terrorisme
vous n'ignorez pas et je me suis exprimé
devant la commission d' enquête sur les
réseaux 10 à 10 une commission
visionnaire du ce qu'elle s'est
installée elle est installée il ya
plusieurs mois et je lui ai fait part
mais je suis à la disposition du sénat
de des dispositions que nous avons
prises dans le domaine pénitentiaire
dans le domaine de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse et dans le
domaine de dans le domaine judiciaire
ainsi dans le renforcement de la section
anti terroriste de paris par conséquent
la politique est là mais il faut éviter
les confusions monsieur le sénateur est
justement la culture de cette haute
assemblée c'est le travail en commun ce
sont les rapports avec un membre de
l'opposition un membre de la majorité ce
sont des commissions ou d'aider des
expériences différentes la commission
dont je viens de parler d' enquête sur
le réseau djihadiste c'est une
commission qui rassemble des sens des
sénateurs de sensibilités différentes
mais appartenant aussi à des commissions
différentes par conséquent voilà le
sélectionneur nous avons fait le choix
de la responsabilité nous n'avons jamais
pensé à vous rendre au responsable des
crimes de mohamed merah en 2012 s'était
pourtant sous votre législature et sous
les lois que vous aviez voté mais à
aucun moment et même en pleine campagne
électorale l'actuel président de la
république en tout cas en tant que
candidat a été absolument faux populaire
dans son attitude de façon à ne pas
transférer sur les institutions sur les
responsables politiques des crimes qui
sont commis par des individus
merci la parole est à yvon collin pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues dimanche
dernier la victoire aux élections
législatives du parti de gauche syriza a
fait resurgir le spectre du défaut de
paiement des emprunts grecs
replaçant au coeur de l'actualité les
modèles de pondération des actifs
bancaires mises en oeuvre au cours de
ces dernières années par l'union
européenne quel que soit notre
appréciation sur cette nouvelle donne
politique le cas grec délivre un message
invite à une inflexion de la politique
monétaire de la zone euro d'ailleurs
nous y sommes puisque quelques jours
avant les élections en grèce la banque
centrale européenne a décidé d'entamer
un programme d'assouplissement
quantitatif
en effet la bce a décidé de racheter
massivement des titres de dette publique
et privée à raison de 60 milliards
d'euros par mois jusqu'à la fin 2016
soit au total
1140 milliards d'euros au total comme
vous le savez mes chers collègues il
s'agit d'éloigner le risque
déflationniste la bce visant une cible
d'inflation à 2 % ce ministre le
confirmera peut-être un taux susceptible
de ramener plus de croissance au sein de
la zone euro les dirigeants européens
attendait depuis longtemps cette
décision à tel point que grillant la
politesse à la bce le président françois
hollande a annoncé trois jours avant la
bce pour autant le quantitative easing
est il la potion magique pour relancer
l'économie en europe nous connaissons la
presse sa principale vertu augmenter la
quantité de mon et mise en circulation
autrement dit faire tourner la planche à
billets a ainsi entraîné la dépréciation
de l'euro pour soutenir les exportations
européennes or si l'on peut espérer de
ce coup de pouce qui a déjà été anticipé
par les marchés on sait que son impact
ne sera pas significatif ou de sera
significatif que si des réformes
structurelles se poursuivent donc si les
investisseurs sont suffisamment rassurés
par les politiques économiques que nous
mettons en oeuvre monsieur le ministre
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais connaître
monsieur le ministre la position du
gouvernement sur la décision de la bce
et comment la france compte la compagnie
merci pour vous reprendre la parole et à
monsieur michel sapin et des finances et
des comptes publics j'avais la parole
monsieur nomination c'est le président
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
vous m'interrogez principalement même si
vous avez fait allusion à la situation
grecque j'aurai l'occasion d'y répondre
dans d'autres questions principalement
sur la politique menée par la banque
centrale européenne je vais vous le dire
très clairement le gouvernement français
avait depuis longtemps souhaité une
évolution de la politique monétaire de
la banque centrale européenne depuis
plus de neuf mois nous demandions que
cette évolution et lieu elle a eu lieu
elle a été renforcée encore la semaine
dernière et c'est une bonne chose
d'abord parce que l'euro était arrivé à
un niveau d'appréciation par rapport aux
principales monnaies du monde pense bien
sûr au dollar mais on peut penser à
d'autres monnaies qui était largement
surévalué par rapport à sa valeur et
s'est immédiatement un obstacle en
particulier pour nos grandes industries
exportatrices je pense bien sûr à
l'industrie aéronautique mais on a
chacun dans notre tête des exemples de
cette nature-là deuxième côté le
deuxième côté positif c'est que les taux
d'intérêt ont considérablement baissé
ayez en tête monsieur le sénateur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices cueilli hier soir le taux
d'intérêt à 10 ans pour un bon français
pour une dette française est tombé à
0,5 pour cent un demi pour cent à 10 ans
c'est vous dire combien les
investisseurs aujourd'hui il faut
mériter leur confiance dans la durée
font confiance à la france mais il faut
aussi que l'ensemble de notre économie
puissent profiter de cette aubaine et en
particulier les entreprises elles mêmes
et c'est la raison pour laquelle la
troisième décision qui a été prise par
la banque centrale européenne la semaine
dernière est une bonne décision puisque
elle va par des mécanismes que je ne
vais pas décrire ici permettre qu'il y
ait plus d'argent dans l'économie
européenne plus d'argent dans l'économie
française et à partir de là une plus
grande possibilité de croissance la
croissance la croissance la croissance
parce que c'est la croissance qui nous
permettra de répondre aux questions en
termes d'emplois qui sont évidemment les
questions les plus prégnantes mais la
politique monétaire ne peut pas tout et
si nous nous attendions que de la
politique monétaire un résultat positif
nous nous trompe rio et c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous y faisiez allusion il
faut aussi faire évoluer un certain
nombre d'autres curseurs d'abord le
curseur budgétaire c'est une discussion
que nous avons avec l'europe il faut
diminuer nos déficits mais un rythme qui
soit un rythme compatible avec le
soutien de la croissance et puis les
réformes de structure nous les avons
engagé d'autres sont en cours de
discussion au parlement et dans le cadre
du bicamérisme auquel vous avez rendus
et nous rendons hommage vous aurez aussi
à débattre de la loi macron et d'autres
réformes ensuite viendront une politique
monétaire positive une politique
budgétaire adapté des politiques de
structures et des réformes de structure
voilà la clé du retour à la croissance
en europe et en france merci monsieur le
ministre merci pour cet hommage au micam
est riche la parole est à andré gattolin
pour le groupe écologiste avait la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'histoire semble parfois
resservir les mêmes plats il ya trois
ans presque jour pour jour j'intervenais
ici même et et j'interpellais le
gouvernement de l'époque sur la
situation en grèce alors où la troïka
obtenaient l'approbation de son second
plan daide est de rigueur sans surprise
trois ans après l'économie grecque reste
percluses et le peuple se débat toujours
dandy d'admissibles souffrance le
contexte social économique et politique
a pourtant beaucoup évolué depuis à la
fois en grèce est à la fois au niveau
européen au printemps 2012 les pays de
l'union était tout entier accaparé par
l'objectif de réduction de la dette et
de la dépense publique alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous interrogeons
enfin sur les effets d'une croissance en
berne d'un chômage toujours plus élevées
et d'une quasi déflation totalement
contreproductive pour nos économies en
2012 pour éviter un défaut de paiement
qui ont entraîné l'effondrement de la
zone euro nous avons imposées à la grèce
les éternels recettes du fmi baisse des
salaires des retraites des emplois
publics des remboursements de santé mais
nous sommes nous préoccuper de
véritables des véritables problèmes
structurels rencontrées par la grèce et
sur lequel l'europe a pudiquement fermé
les yeux depuis l'adhésion de ce pays en
1980 je veux parler bien sûr des
incroyable privilège dont bénéficie une
petite oligarchie qui regroupe armateurs
à églises orthodoxes grands possesseurs
de comptes à l'étranger non nous avons
surtout pressurer ceux qui étaient les
plus faciles à pressurer c'est pourquoi
il ne faut pas s'étonner du résultat
sorti des urnes la semaine passée
pourtant dans les jours précédant la
victoire devenue inéluctable de syriza
nous avons enfin entendu des voix se
disant prête à rediscuter le plan
d'austérité de la grèce en échange de
mesures comme la nécessaire réforme du
cadastre la lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale alors monsieur le
ministre nous croyons fermement que dans
le contexte actuel il revient
aujourd'hui à notre pays de prendre
l'initiative pour redonner un véritable
sens politique aux propositions qui
seront faits par l'union c'est pourquoi
nous aimerions monsieur le ministre
savoir quelles propositions concrètes la
france entend avancer pour relever un
défi qui n'est pas qu'économique et
financier
mais aujourd'hui profondément politique
car mettant en jeu les valeurs
démocratiques supposé fondé le projet
européen chevaux remercie bien merci
pour vous répondre la parole et à michel
sapin ministre des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur je vous cherche des yeux pardon
la grèce la situation grecque le
résultat des élections premières choses
nous respectons la démocratie ici comme
ailleurs en france comme en grèce le
peuple s'est librement exprimée
clairement exprimé il y à une nouvelle
majorité il y à un nouveau gouvernement
il ya de nouveaux responsables dans tous
les sens du terme en grèce et c'est avec
cela que évidemment les gouvernements de
l'union européenne l'union européenne
elle-même doivent dialoguer et discuté
avec la volonté de chercher des
solutions aux vrais problèmes qui
aujourd'hui se pose en grèce le premier
des problèmes qui se posent en grèce de
manière encore plus accentué que dans le
reste de l'europe c'est la question de
la croissance un pays qui a perdu un
quart de sa richesse de sa valeur en
l'espace de quelques années est un pays
qui est profondément dans la souffrance
profondément dans la difficulté
25% de pipe en moins par rapport aux
années 2009 2010 voyez ce que ça veut
dire en termes de baisses de salaires en
termes de baisse de rémunération de
termes de baisses de pensions bref un
peuple dans la difficulté dans la
souffrance qui s'est exprimé et nous
devons d'abord et avant tout le
respecter deuxièmement c'est un pays qui
a de vraies difficultés de vrais
problèmes et personne ne pourra abolir
du seul fait d'une élection la réalité
de ces problèmes logo la grèce a rétabli
son équilibre budgétaire comme on dit
primaire elle est en capacité de payer
l'ensemble de ses dépenses de
fonctionnement et de ses investissements
il ne faudra pas que se dégradent cet
équilibre sinon ce sera extrêmement
difficile pour la grèce parce qu'elle ne
trouvera personne
pour lui prêter l'argent nécessaire et
ya la question de la dette et de la
soutenabilité de cette dette parce que
175 % de dette par rapport au pib aucun
pays ne peut vivre longuement avec une
telle situation ce sujet n'est pas
nouveau il était sur la table avant
l'élection de dimanche dernier il est
sur la table aujourd'hui en tout état de
cause il aurait fallu parler de la
soutenabilité de la dette grecque quelle
que fût le gouvernement issu de ces
élections nous allons le faire et j'ai
souhaité le président la république
d'abord et moi même nous avons souhaité
être un pays qui facilite le dialogue et
qui facilite la recherche d'une solution
avec la grèce c'est ça notre état
d'esprit tout en discutant aussi avec
les autorités grecques des réformes
nécessaires tout particulièrement dans
le domaine de la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale dans le domaine de la lutte
contre l' optimisation fiscale parce que
c'est aussi un des points sur lesquels
l'offre la grèce devra se réformer
merci
la parole à leur collègue eric bocquet
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen lever la parole merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
minis sur collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministres des
finances et des comptes publics
nous resterons en grèce si vous voulez
bien les élections de dimanche ont donné
une majorité large à la coalition
dirigée par monsieur alexis tsipras ce
le peuple grec a ainsi clairement
exprimé son rejet des politiques
d'austérité imposées par la troïka union
européenne banque centrale européenne et
fonds monétaire international les
résultats de ces politiques d'austérité
sont édifiants 27 % de chômage dont 55 %
chez les plus jeunes dette publique
passer effectivement de 120% du pib à
175% la grèce est en état de véritable
chaos économique et social
cette situation a également été vécu
comme une atteinte à la dignité même du
peuple grec les partisans de syriza
étaient plus nombreux dimanche soir
qu'il ne l'était la veille ainsi le
commissaire européen monsieur pierre
moscovici s'est levé il ya quelques
semaines encore le travail accompli par
le gouvernement de monsieur samaras en
indiquant je cite qu après tant
d'efforts tant de choses accomplies par
le gouvernement grec il serait dommage
de ne pas continuer fin de citation
un hebdomadaire satirique du mercredi
indiquait hier que monsieur alexis
tsipras saab et adressé une lettre le 9
mai 2012 au président de la république
française nouvellement élu je cite nous
espérons que votre élection et le
résultat réussi par la gauche en grèce
nous entraîneront vers une europe
sociale exempte de mesures d'austérité
rigoureuses et des exigences strictes du
pacte financier fin de citation nous
pensons monsieur le ministre qu'il est
désormais temps de répondre à cette
lettre le message fort adressé par le
peuple grec dimanche est une remise en
cause fondamentale des principes du
dernier traité européen le nouveau
gouvernement grec s'est déjà attelé à la
tâche immense qui l'attend en décidant
notamment l'arrêt du processus de
privatisation de grandes infrastructures
tels les porcs et certains aéroports
régionaux dans le même temps notre
ministre de l'économie prévoit
exactement inverse en ce moment même à
l'assemblée nationale face aux pressions
des marchés financiers et des agences de
notation qui s'expriment déjà la grèce
va avoir besoin du soutien et de la
solidarité concrète des peuples et des
gouvernements européens
monsieur ministre voici ma question
quelle initiative le gouvernement
français envisage t-il de prendre au
plan national et au plan européen avec
nos partenaires de l'union pour soutenir
le gouvernement de monsieur de sipera ce
dans son projet de reconstruction de
l'économie et de la société grecque
merci mon cher collègue pour vous
répondre la parole et au ministre des
finances michel sapin
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur
je ne suis pas là pour surveiller les
échanges postaux entre les uns et les
autres c'est pas dans mes compétences
par contre il était dans mes compétences
de rentrer en contact avec mon homologue
le nouveau ministre des finances qui a
eu d'ailleurs la courtoisie de me dire
qu'il se déplacerait à paris pour me
rencontrer pour que nous puissions
discuter de tous les sujets que vous
venez d'aborder il sera là lundi
prochain et nous aurons une séance de
travail longue approfondie pour voir
quelles sont d'abord les propositions du
gouvernement grec parce que j'entends
beaucoup de gens en france le lui dis
pas pour vous qui s'exprime au nom du
gouverneur grec lui-même le nouveau
gouvernement grec sans pour autant que
celui-ci est encore eu le temps
d'exprimer de manière ordonnée de
manière responsable au sens d'un
gouvernement responsable exactement ces
propositions et donc c'est la première
chose le premier respect que nous devons
à ce gouvernement c'est de lui laisser
le temps de s'installer et d'exprimer
les volontés qui sont les siennes y
compris dans le dialogue avec l'union
européenne j'ai dit déjà quel était
notre disposition d'esprit la france
veut faciliter le dialogue entre la
grèce et l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne et les institutions de
l'union européenne c'est indispensable
pour tous le chaos pour la grèce serait
terrible pour la grèce et serait une
mauvaise chose pour l'europe monsieur le
sénateur j'ai entendu le gouvernement
grec d'aujourd'hui son premier ministre
qui m'a dit qui m'a dit qui a dit nous
ne voulons pas sortir de la zone euro et
il a raison ce serait une mauvaise chose
pour la grèce j'ai entendu le même
premier ministre dire nous ne remettons
pas en cause les traités et les règles
européennes
il l'a dit il a eu raison de le dire car
quand on est dans une zone comme la zone
euro on doit en respecter les contenus
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il n'ya
aucune plage de discussion évidemment il
y à des plages des discussions il ya des
possibilités pour d'abord mettre en
oeuvre des programmes de réformes le
nouveau gouvernement veut réformer
l'administration fiscale il a raison
c'est un reproche que nous faisions au
précédent gouvernement de ne pas le
faire avec suffisamment de volonté il
veut lutter contre la fraude fiscale
nous aussi nous le faisons en france
nous voulons soit fait en europe et il
ya du chemin à faire aussi en grèce pour
que chacun paye les impôts qu'il doit en
l'occurrence mais s'il ya plus de
rentrées fiscales en grèce il pourra y
avoir évidemment d'autres dépenses du
budget grec mais de manière équilibrée
enfin un mot sur la dette la dette
grecque ce n'est pas une dette vis-à-vis
des marchés financiers il n'y a plus de
dettes vis-à-vis du privé en grèce il
n'y a qu'une dette vis à vis des
institutions publiques ou vis-à-vis de
chacun des pays la france par exemple à
une exposition la france nous le
contribuable français de 40,2 milliards
ça n'est pas rien discuté de la dette
oui pour en alléger le fardeau annuler
la dette non car ce serait transféré le
poids du contribuable grec vers le
contribuable français
ministre des finances grec a dit que ça
il n'en voulait pas et moi non plus mais
si la parole est à monsieur alain néri
pour le groupe socialiste
sur le ministre chargé du travail de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle mes chers collègues de
nombreux jeunes de tous niveaux
scolaires souhaitent bénéficier d'une
formation professionnelle en alternance
pour préparer qui un ca paix qui master
voire un bts et chacun on connaît
aujourd'hui l'intérêt la qualité de
cette formation
très nombreux sur les organismes de
formation et les écoles qui proposent
des formations théoriques souvent
onéreuses d'ailleurs à charge pour les
jeunes de trouver
une entreprise d'accueil acceptant
d'assurer la formation pratique très
déterminé et très motivés les jeunes se
lancent à la recherche de leur maître de
stage mais bien vite il déchante
car ils vont de refus un refus leur
déception celle de leurs parents voire
de leurs grands parents est grande après
avoir espéré faire une formation
professionnelle qui déboucherait sur un
métier un emploi
désabusés ils vont s'inscrire à pôle
emploi ce qui peut d'ailleurs expliqué
monsieur le ministre en partie
l'augmentation du nombre de jeunes
chômeurs en octobre et en novembre
monsieur le ministre on ne peut accepter
une telle situation car l'insertion
professionnelle et l'insertion sociale
vont souvent de pair aussi il me paraît
urgent de pouvoir répondre souhaitent
ces jeunes qui veulent préparer leur vie
professionnelle par une formation en
alternance il faut leur redonner
l'espoir il faut que les entreprises
fassent un effort pour répondre
favorablement à leur volonté et leur
désir la formation professionnelle des
jeunes en alternance est un problème
d'importance et de solidarité nationale
comme l'était d'ailleurs l'emploi des
personnes handicapées lorsque l'on a
créé spécialement
l'obligation d'embaucher un pourcentage
de personnes handicapées dans
l'entreprise monsieur le ministre ne
pourrait-on pas envisager pour ces
jeunes une mesure de même nature ce
serait à mon avis une mesure citoyenne
qu'ils attendent avec impatience
par l'état françois rebsamen
ministre du travail et de l'emploi vous
avez la parole je mets ici monsieur le
président messieurs les sénateurs à
monsieur le sénateur alain néri merci
d'avoir posé cette question sur un sujet
qui est éminemment consensuelle et qui
me permet de remettre un éclairage sur
l'apprentissage
tous les acteurs s'accordent sur tous
les bancs pour dire que l'apprentissage
est une voie d'excellence qu'il nous
faut conforter pour les entreprises
parce que elle permet à ces entreprises
de trouver les compétences nécessaires
mais aussi pour les jeunes puisque cette
voie d'insertion à permet aux jeunes de
s'insérer et 70% des jeunes trouvent un
travail en sortant de l'apprentissage et
autour du président de la république le
19 septembre un certain nombre d'actions
un plan d'action a été arrêté en faveur
de la relance de l'apprentissage
il a été fait avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux et il ya eu
unanimité région et partenaires sociaux
quelques points que je rappelle
rapidement sur le plan financier des
mesures concrètes ont été prises
adoptée dans le budget 2015 pour un
montant de 200 millions d'euros les
entreprises pourront affecter plus de
taxe d'apprentissage au cfa au centre de
formation d'apprentis et puis une aide
au recrutement d'un apprenti
supplémentaire d'un montant de 1000
euros est accordée à toutes les
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés et
ça s'ajoute cette aide s'ajoute à la
prime à l'apprentissage dans les tpe les
entreprises ont insisté à l'occasion de
cette réunion sur les freins à l
embauche que pouvaient constituer
l'autorisation préalable d'embauché vous
le savez qu'il devait obtenir de
l'inspection du travail pour les travaux
dits dangereux dès le mois de mai 2005
cette autorisation sera cette demande
d'autorisation sera supprimé elle sera
remplacée par une déclaration bien
évidemment il ne s'agit pas de mettre en
danger les jeunes mais de faciliter
l'entrée de ces jeunes dans l'alternance
et d'enlever les freins que les
entreprises peuvent voir venir par
ailleurs une bourse de l'apprentissage
sera constituée afin que ces jeunes qui
écrivent et vous le savez pertinemment
où tous sur tous les bancs à tous à
toutes les entreprises sans avoir de
réponse puisse savoir exactement dans
leur région les postes qui sont
disponibles et stages qui sont
disponibles dans les entreprises et
c'est une grande et c'est une grande et
belle cause l'apprentissage monsieur le
sénateur et c'est pour cela que je
compte sur vous pour populariser ces
mesures est rappelé aux entreprises qu
aimer l'apprentissage c'est bien
embaucher des apprentis c'est mieux si
monsieur le ministre a parlé de notre
collègue pierre frogier pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole vous chers collègues du
président je vous remercie ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'outre-mer je vais bien sûr évoqué la
crise politique que traverse la nouvelle
calédonie en ce début d'année et pour
que les choses soient claires il s'agit
en réalité d'une nouvelle péripétie liés
à l' usage abusif été tournées de
l'article 121 dalle organique de 1999
cet article permet en effet
malheureusement une formation
minoritaire au sein du gouvernement d'en
provoquer la chute en faisant
démissionner l'ensemble de ces
proprement une telle utilisation de la
loi avait déjà été dénoncée par le
conseil d'état qui avait jugé en avril
2011 quand tu entends ainsi d'empêcher
le fonctionnement normal des
institutions ce détournement avait le
caractère d'une manoeuvre électorale
alors qu'en est il exactement
c'est sûr on calédonie comme ailleurs
dans tout régime d'assemblée seule une
majorité de ses membres peut s'enfuir et
son exécutif
mais en l'espèce faute de trouver cette
majorité l'article 121 a été une
nouvelle fois détourné son objet par un
groupe minoritaire dans le but au
gouvernement dans le but affiché de
s'emparer de la seule présidence de ce
gouvernement c'est ce qui provoque cette
situation inédite et absurde où la
nouvelle calédonie aujourd'hui est doté
de deux gouvernements composés de façon
identique l'un élu les incapables
désigné en son sein son président et
donc inopérant l'autre démissionnaire
est chargé d'expédier les affaires
courantes et le comble ce sont ceux là
mêmes qui sont à l'origine de ce blocage
qui viennent madame la ministre se
retourner vers vous afin que vous
régliez cette situation en réponse
vous avez récemment indiqué que l'état
prendrait ses responsabilités
mais quelles responsabilités
envisagez-vous la dissolution de nos
assemblées afin de procéder à de
nouvelles élections alors que le congrès
de la nouvelle-calédonie fonctionne
normalement et vient d'adopter à
l'unanimité plusieurs textes avant la
fin de la session où avez vous
l'intention comme je l'entends dire de
proposer une nouvelle modification de la
loi organique afin d'ouvrir la
possibilité d'une élection du président
du gouvernement à la majorité relative
ce serait bien sûr une nouvelle atteinte
à l'esprit et à la lettre de l'accord de
nouméa
mais bien plus encore ce serait la
remise en cause de ce modèle de
gouvernement d'unité calédonienne qui
oblige les partisans du maintien de la
calédonie dans la france et les
indépendantistes à la recherche
permanente du consensus dans ce cas que
reste-t-il que resterait-il de cet
accord alors dans les ministres puisque
vous avez affirmé devant une autre
assemblée que l'état prendrait ses
responsabilités
je vous demande pas cette situation
quelles responsabilités
allez-vous prendre merci mon cher
collègue pour nous répondre la parole
est à madame la ministre d outre-mer dom
george pau-langevin vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à monsieur le
sénateur frogier vous avez tout à fait
raison de souligner combien la situation
actuelle en nouvelle calédonie nous
préoccupe il est clair que nous sommes à
un moment où nous avons besoin de
travailler pour préparer la sortie de
l'accord de nouméa et nous avons donc
besoin que toutes les parties et tous
les élus puissent être travailler
ensemble et avancées pour résoudre les
problèmes qui se posent mais encore une
fois il me semble qu'aujourd'hui si nous
pouvons souhaiter que les élus exercent
leurs responsabilités se voit et trouve
une solution pour pouvoir élire ce qui
est indispensable
un président et un vice-président à
cette assemblée
il n'est pas imaginé par nous de nous
substituer aux élus alors surtout que
nous sommes sur une démarche qui tend à
donner avoir trouvé pour la nouvelle
calédonie régime d'autonomie maximale
donc dans la mesure où nous ne voulons
absolument pas stigmatisé les élus nous
voulons simplement leur demander d'être
fidèles à leurs responsabilités et à
leur engagement pour la nouvelle
calédonie actuellement vous avez
envisagé un certain nombre de solutions
dites vous bien que nous n'y sommes nous
sommes ne sommes pas là aujourd'hui le
haut-commissaire essaye surtout de
recevoir les uns et des autres de
rapprocher les points de vue pour qu'une
solution raisonnable puisse être trouvé
mais nous ne pouvons pas imaginer que
nous aurions une intervention qui serait
de nature à en quelque sorte rétablir
une sorte de tutelle sur la nouvelle
calédonie à un moment où le souhait de
tout le monde est plutôt d'aller à
linverse donc ce que nous pouvons dire
simplement c'est que aujourd'hui nous
sommes prêts à passer le temps
nécessaire pour trouver une solution qui
soit une solution de consensus nous
espérons qu'elle va arriver d'autant que
pour tous les problèmes que nous avons à
régler avant la consultation de 2018
dans tous les cas ce que nous essayons
de privilégier
c'est précisément le consensus donc là
encore on y mettra le temps qu'il faut
mais j'espère que nous allons trouver
une solution et comme cette année nous
avons démarré sous des auspices de drame
nous avons démarré avec joel le mois de
janvier finalement une espèce de volonté
d'union nationale pour régler les
problèmes essayons de maintenir l'esprit
du 11 janvier en nouvelle calédonie pour
aboutir à une solution merci madame la
ministre la parole est notre collègue
philippe paul pour le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire vous avez la
parole de mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget mais le sujet en
question a déjà été évoqué en termes
quasiment similaire par ma collègue
doisneau tout à l'heure donc si vous me
permettez monsieur le président j'ai
raccourci volontairement la question et
je voudrais évoquer un sujet important
qui n'a pas été jusqu'à présent mais ça
sera très court si vous me permettez
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la décision le 15 janvier
dernier de la banque nationale suisse
d'abandonner le taux plancher de
conversion du franc suisse a frappé de
plein fouet les communes qui ont
souscrit des emprunts dits toxiques
indexés sur la parité entre l'euro et
cette monnaie
l'envolée du franc suisse conséquence de
cette décision que s'est accompagnée
d'une augmentation aussi forte que prévu
des taux d'intérêt de ses emprunts dont
les communes avaient déjà les plus
grandes difficultés à se défaire un
millier de collectivités mais aussi une
des dizaines d'hôpitaux seraient
concernés si je prends le cas de ma
commune douarnenez le taux d'un emprunt
de cinq millions et demi d'euros
souscrit en 2007 est ainsi passé de 5
71% à 9 90 % générant en augmentation la
nuitée de frais financiers deux cent
mille euros
ce taux pourrait très vite monté à 15 %
portant l'augmentation de ses frais
financiers à 240000 euros et encore je
ne m'estime pas le plus mal loti bien
des communes voyant les taux de ces
emprunts qu'ils ont souscrit dépasser
largement les 20 voire les 25% cette
explosion de frais financiers sorte de
double peine pour ces communes déjà
sinistré par ces emprunts toxiques pose
la question de l'utilité du fonds de
soutien dans son fonctionnement et dans
son montant actuel il a craint qu'il
soit plus à la hauteur du problème
désormais posée à ces communes le
montant de l'indemnité de sortie des
emprunts toxiques devenant inabordable
aussi monsieur le ministre pourriez vous
nous indiquez les initiatives que le
gouvernement entend prendre dans les
plus brefs délais pour eddy ces
collectivités et ses établissements
hospitaliers à faire face à une
situation exceptionnelle qui met
gravement en péril l'équilibré de leurs
finances
et pour terminer monsieur le président
mes chers collègues puisque le sujet n'a
pas été évoqué
comme comme français comme élu comme
aussi réserviste je voudrais rendre un
hommage à nos militaires de l'armée de
l'air des cd ou gravement blessés en
mission lors du crash aérien du 26
janvier albacete en espagne mes pensées
et j'en suis certain nos pensées à tous
et à toutes attristé vont vers leurs
familles endeuillées meurtri ainsi que
vers l'ensemble des personnes deux
armées aujourd'hui dans la peine alors
qu'elles accomplissent une tâche est un
devoir exemplaire souvent dans des
conditions difficiles voire très
difficile au quotidien je vous remercie
merci l'enchère collègues j'aurais dire
au ministre de la défense que le sénat
mardi s'est associé à la pensée pour ces
militaires et leurs familles je remercie
philippe paul d'avoir permis que ceux ci
soient aussi traduit à cet instant
monsieur le secrétaire d'état christian
eckert pour répondre à la question de
notre collègue oui merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs le sénateur
merci de cet hommage à l'élu meurthe et
mosellan que je suis daniel renner je
pense associera bien sûr l'ensemble du
gouvernement pour l'occasion je crois
mardi matin de rendre un hommage
solennel aux invalides à nos militaires
décédés
merci de me donner l'occasion de
précisez la réponse que j'ai pu faire
tout à l'heure à votre collègue en vous
disant qu'il faut d'abord apprécié je le
disais l'ampleur du phénomène qui évolue
j'allais dire presque deux jours en
jours
il appartiendra à nos spécialistes en
lien avec les élus de savoir s'il est
plus opportun de tenter de déboucler des
contrats à cet instant si il est
malheureusement plus délicat de le faire
justement dans cette période de tension
s'il vaut mieux accompagner
le remboursement et la négociation désir
à des indemnités de remboursement
anticipé ou s'il vaut mieux aider les
collectivités à passer une année plus ce
cap difficile c'est tout l'enjeu du
travail que nous sommes en train de
conduire et je le dis que nous ferons
concertation avec les élus et les
responsables concernés et probablement
je relève le probablement et en
informant votre commission des finances
est l'occasion de le faire je crois hier
matin si ma mémoire est bonne une
première fois mais à la lumière de
l'évolution de ce dossier chaud nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
une chose est certaine je crois que nous
devrons orienter notre appui en nous
basant sur quelques indicateurs que nous
avions peut-être pas suffisamment prises
en compte en tout cas que nous pouvions
laisser de côté compte tenu du milliard
et demi disponibles à savoir
probablement concentré n'osait d' un peu
plus sur les collectivités pour
lesquelles la situation deviendrait
proprement insoutenable va évoquer des
taux autour de 10% certaines ont des
taux autour de 25% sur sénateurs
pardon de vous le dire mais tout ça
évolue de deux jours en jours et donc
nous allons voir avec les montants
disponibles
comment répartir au mieux et concentrés
au mieux nos z vers les collectivités ou
les établissements notamment spitalier
ceci relève d'un autre fonds pour
les aider à passer ce cap le voir dans
quelles conditions nous pourrons et à
quel moment au mieux traiter ce dossier
très complexe où les responsabilités
sont diverses mais ça nous l'avons déjà
évoqué à plusieurs moments
la parole et matin entre collègues qui
arinc l'hérault bien entendu vous avez
pu voir que l'horaire avait été percuté
forte heureusement public sénat
retransmis en ce moment il dit à notre
collègue et sa question vous avez la
parole pour le groupe socialiste sur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues lors de
son discours au forum économique mondial
à davos le 23 janvier dernier le
président de la république française est
revenu sur les terribles événements de
janvier et a rappelé la solidarité
exceptionnelle ce sont ses mots qui les
a suivis cet admirable de solidarité
doit se retrouver dans les actions mises
en oeuvre dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste pas seulement au niveau
national mais au niveau international et
notamment européens la réponse doit être
globale internationale et partager la
france ne pourra pas tout faire ne
pourra pas agir seul on sait que la
propagande la radicalisation le
recrutement des terroristes sont
facilités par l'accessibilité la
mondialisation et la rapidité d'internet
particulièrement par les réseaux sociaux
face à cette menace mondiale il est
nécessaire que les différents pays
salies se soutiennent et s'entraident
le programme de stockholm mis en place
par l'union européenne pour la période
2010 2014 mettez l'accent notamment sur
des actions de prévention et de
protection parmi lesquels la lutte
contre le recrutement et l'armement des
terroristes et une surveillance accrue
dans les transports au vu des attentats
perpétrés ces dernières années en europe
on est en droit de se demander si ces
actions sont bien adaptés et si leur
mise en place est suffisamment rapide je
pense notamment aux passenger name louis
corde dans le parlement européen bloque
la mise en place depuis 2011 malgré les
demandes insistantes des états d'autre
part autres structures europe et aucune
part dans structures européennes
existent actuellement pour coordonner
des actions spécifiques liées à la lutte
antiterroriste monsieur le ministre
considérez vous que les actions du
programme de stockholm était suffisante
la période couverte est arrivé à son
terme quel but donc le temps tiré de
l'application de ces actions comme cela
a été annoncé le sommet européen du 12
février prochain sera consacré à ce
sujet l'europe at-elle la volonté de
s'engager plus intensément d'accentuer
la lutte anti terroriste sur son
territoire notamment son volet
opérationnel pour est envisagée
notamment la création au sein de l'union
européenne d'une cellule dédiée à la
lutte antiterroriste afin de définir le
périmètre d'action les mettre en oeuvre
sur le terrain et coordonnée au niveau
européen les différentes actions
nationales ainsi que les changes des
renseignements en amont entre les états
membres
merci ma chère collègue pour vous
répondre la parole et à jean yves le
drian ministre de la défense monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices madame la
sénatrice pourrait tout d'abord vous
demander de bien vouloir excuser
le ministre l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve qui se trouve en ce moment à
une réunion des ministres de l'intérieur
de l'union européenne a à riga il m'a
chargé de vous répondre sur vos
préoccupations et en particulier sur le
calendrier européen que vous avez bien
voulu rappeler tout à l'heure il y aura
comme vous le savez un conseil européen
le 12 février qui sera particulièrement
consacrée à la lutte contre le
terrorisme et à cette occasion le
gouvernement français présente la
république en particulier aura à coeur
de faire avancer quatre orientations que
je voudrais évoquer ici tout d'abord la
détection le contrôle ou l'entravent du
déplacement des combattants étrangers
terroristes ou des réseaux cela
signifiera une modification des règles
du code schengen et en particulier la
possibilité de la consultation
systématique du système d'information
schengen lors du franchissement des
frontières extérieures par les personnes
jouissant du droit à la libre
circulation c'est un point significatif
qui sera mis sur la table la discussion
le deuxième point que vous avez évoqué
vous-même concerne
l'idée d'un pnr européen système
d'échangé de données des passagers de
vols pour un meilleur repérage des vous
mangez à 10 vous avez rappelé que le
parlement européen mais jusqu'à présent
bloqué la procédure et il importe
désormais que chacun fasse l'effort de
comprendre l'urgence de l'adoption de
cet outil est bien là cazeneuve se
rendra la semaine prochaine à bruxelles
pour rencontrer les députés européens à
cet égard le troisième point
qui sera à l'ordre du jour aussi du du
conseil du 12 février concerne le
partenariat avec des grands opérateurs
de l'internet est indispensable pour le
signalement rapide de contenus incitant
à la haine la terreur et dans la case 9
envisage de se rendre aux états unis
pour rencontrer les acteurs mais aussi
envisage que l'union européenne soit un
lieu particulièrement appropriés pour
lutter contre le phénomène de la
radicalisation à partir d'internet et
puis le dernier point concerne le
renforcement de la lutte contre le
trafic d'armes à feu en europe par
l'échangé d'informations et les
opérations conjointes des polices en
europe voilà quatre sujets lourds qui
pourront permettre de faire avancer la
lutte contre le terrorisme sans compter
un sujet qui est à la fois de la
compétence de bernard cazeneuve et de la
mienne qui est la bonne coordination en
matière de renseignement et de ce côté
là les choses vont plutôt bien vous le
savez madame la sénatrice tous les
démocraties sont concernés par cette
menace terroriste doivent y répondre
ensemble c'est ce à quoi s'emploie le
présentable lesquelles le gouvernement
comme je voulais indiqué li un instant
merci monsieur le ministre voilà vous
venez d'assister aux questions
d'actualité au sénat nous on refait la
séance mensuelle suspension ce soit
on refait la séance sur public sénat une
séance de questions d'actualité
pas comme les autres ça un petit peu
chauffé dans cette séance de questions
d'actualité